[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce premier numéro
de la saison de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire
nous nous intéresserons au tourisme
d'affaires à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
récemment une soixantaine d'entreprises
s'étaient donné rendez-vous à montigny
le bretonneux l'occasion du maïs des
elles sont nombreuses à miser sur ce
secteur en pleine croissance
le ski-club l'espace dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat sur notre territoire
vient d'accueillir cinq nouvelles
start-up
parmi elles l'équipe de l'application
wii sports qui va pouvoir bénéficier de
plusieurs outils
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique
nous reviendrons notamment sur
l'implantation d'une nouvelle enseigne
culturelle dans les yvelines
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
on ouvre ce 7,8 aequo avec un chiffre
333 1659 euros le ski tube l'incubateur
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines vient d'obtenir cette
subvention européenne par le biais de la
région ile-de-france l'agglomération
avaient répondu à l'appel à projet
accueil accompagnement des entreprises
innovantes
il faut savoir que cette somme
correspond environ à un tiers du
financement global du ski cube
elle a pour but d'accompagner les
porteurs de projets innovants alors le
ski tube on va d'ailleurs continuer à en
parler puisqu'il a accueilli le 18
septembre sa deuxième promotion d'un
cube et concrètement cinq start up du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
viennent de rejoindre l'espace dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat et à l'innovation
reportage mettre en relation tous les
sportifs d'île de france par le biais
d'une application c'était le pari il y a
cinq mois de wii sports après plus de
1000 téléchargements le projet va
pouvoir grandir grâce aux skis cube
l'équipe vient tout juste d'intégrer la
deuxième promotion de l'incubateur de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons recherché des moyens pour
pouvoir développer notre entreprise et
les incubateurs on était l'un des
conseils comme ça nous a donné pour
pouvoir développer notre société nous
souhaitons être l'un des acteurs majeurs
dans le sport et en tant qu'application
mobile est vraiment à essayer de d'avoir
une place dans ce marché là en tout cinq
lauréats vont pouvoir profiter d'un
accompagnement administratif de bureau
ou encore de dispositifs de financement
des outils pour développer au mieux
leurs projets nous avons des objectifs
en termes de d'aboutissement de projets
mais nous ne sommes pas dans une soit
exact puisque la création d'entreprise
est un domaine qui est relativement
complexe et qui est soumis à des aléas
que nous maîtrisons pas forcément donc
nous essayons de les suivre au plus près
au fil de l'eau au quotidien mais de
manière périodique tous les six mois
le comité qui les a sélectionnés se
réunit dans le cadre d'un comité de
suivi et
tous les 6 mois donc décide ou non du
maintien de cet accompagnement les
entreprises sélectionnées pourront
bénéficier d'un accompagnement de 24
mois à la fin de cette période elles
pourront voler de leurs propres ailes et
dégager du chiffre d'affaires ouvrons à
présent notre page consacrée au thème de
ce numéro le tourisme d'affaires alors
d'une manière générale ce secteur
représente tout ce qui est lié au
déplacement à but professionnel et tout
ce qui en découle comme le logement la
restauration mais aussi les activités
sportives ou culturelles deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
propose de nombreuses opportunités comme
nous allons le voir dans ce reportage
aller toujours plus haut
atteindre un objectif se dépasser mais
aussi s'entraider des valeurs communes à
l'escaladé au monde de l'entreprise
c'est en partant de ce constat que
l'entreprise verticale art basée à
montigny le bretonneux a décidé de
proposer des sessions entièrement dédié
aux professionnels d'avoir des réunions
travail au début
après une partie sportives ludiques etc
des ateliers qui peuvent se passer sur
la structure escalade
avec des jeux soit pour participer un
peu au challenge soit on peut arriver
aussi également à faire des choses un
petit peu
donc dans la cohésion travailler
ensemble un service qui a besoin par
exemple des services qui se connaissent
passe dans l'entreprise peuvent avoir
également a besoin de se connaître un
peu plus des sociétés de loisirs
proposant des offres pour les
entreprises
il en existe plusieurs sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
le 7 septembre dernier une soixantaine
d'établissements étaient présents à la
ferme du manet pour la première édition
du sky maïs dé la volonté de la
communauté d'agglomération booster le
secteur du tourisme d'affaires
en parlant en échangeant sur différentes
sur différents rendez vous on s'est
rendu compte que d'une part il y avait
une véritable offre que les partenaires
ne se connaissaient pas forcément donc
c'était bien de les réunir et ensuite
que les entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines était sans doute demandeuses
d'événements mais qu'elle n'en avait pas
connaissance obtenir la confiance des
entrepreneurs c'est fondamental c'est
lui qui a la solution plus que moi c'est
lui qui va entraîner ses troupes qui va
investir ou pas qui va rester qui va
partir qui va donc donc nous c'est tout
et amour dans la vie sains et aimé que
l'entreprise se sont entraînés de
l'admiration et l'entreprise aussi bien
sûr et on est là bien sûr pour bien
structurer cesser ses relations de façon
professionnelle de façon respectueuse
pour améliorer la qualité de vie des
salariés pour bien sûr les réseaux
commerciaux là on participe en tout cas
à ce que nos entreprises est bien des
escape game ou encore des balades à vélo
les idées ne manquent pas sur le
territoire pour renforcer la cohésion
des salariés une clientèle qui profite
également à des domaines tels que
grand'maisons à villepreux ch
c'est notre coeur de métier fin
l'événementiel les professionnels tonfa
les 80 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
effectivement en professionnel à prendre
à 20% effectivement que d'aidé aux
particuliers avec l'activité mariage de
boucaines mariages et réceptions mais
notre coeur de métier c'est
l'événementiel donc c'est les pros les
sociétés avec les séminaires et les
conventions et pour aller plus loin la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vient de lancer une
étude pour poser les bases d'un
diagnostic et des préconisations afin de
développer le tourisme d'affaires alors
si le tourisme d'affaires représente
environ 25% du chiffre d'affaires de la
totalité des activités touristiques en
france
quels sont les enjeux pour le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi
quelles sont les perspectives
éléments de réponse avec othman nasri ou
vice président de la région ile de
france chargée du tourisme et françois
navarro directeur général du comité
régional du tourisme un entretien
réalisé le 7 septembre dernier à
l'occasion de la première édition du sky
meist et messieurs bonjour vous êtes
vice président de la région ile de
france en charge du tourisme
françois navarro vous êtes directeur
général du comité régional du tourisme
paris ile de france alors on va évoquer
bien sûr plus précisément le tourisme
d'affaires les avants on va parler du
tourisme au général puisque on va dire
que les taux au beau fixe
si les derniers chiffres sont bons c'est
de bonne augure j'imagine monsieur n'à
through pour watts pour le fichier oui
on a une année 2016 extrêmement
difficile avec une baisse de
fréquentation très fortes notamment des
touristes étrangers
donc ça a été très difficile pour les
professionnels du tourisme et depuis la
fin de l'année dernière
et en particulier depuis le premier
semestre 2010 est on assiste à une vraie
reprise on peut dire que les indicateurs
sont au vert sur partie technique
puisque bien sûr il ya un rebond c'est
logique mais en même temps je crois que
il ya un attrait qui reste très très
fort pour paris et l'île de france
notamment auprès des visiteurs
internationaux et donc il faut qu'on
capitalise sur ses atouts et en même
temps qu'on soit capable de se
réinventer pour qu'on ait toujours plus
de touristes et qu'on vous puisse rester
la première destination touristique au
monde
monsieur navarro est ce que le tourisme
d'affaires a pu profiter aussi de cette
dynamique en 2016 au moment des
attentats des événements qui ont touché
notre destination le tourisme d'affaires
est le segment qui a le plus résisté
il n'y a pas eu de baisse il ya eu une
baisse des exposants mais en tout cas et
des visiteurs mais en tout cas les
salons les rencontres professionnelles
se sont tenues et en 2010 est à nouveau
sur le premier semestre
le tourisme d'affaires tire cette
croissance avec près de la moitié des
arrivées hôtelières en ile-de-france qui
sont dédiés au tourisme d'affaires
alors est-ce que l'on peut pas avoir un
chiffre annuel sur les retombées
économiques du tourisme d'affaires en
ile de france on estime aux aventures de
7 milliards d'euros les retombées
économiques sur le segment affaires sur
un total d'une vingtaine de milliards
d'euros en termes de retombées
économiques
donc c'est un segment extrêmement
important il ya une bataille très forte
avec les autres destinations européennes
et les autres destinations mondiales
pour accueillir les congrès les salons
mais aussi les rencontres
professionnelles comme ici aujourd'hui à
saint quentin
alors justement à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines monsieur nasri
en quoi ce secteur est dynamique en
termes de tourisme d'affaires saint
quentin en yvelines c'est le deuxième
pôle économique de l'ouest parisien
après la défense est une énorme
concentration de dynamisme économique de
sièges sociaux d'entreprises et donc
naturellement c'est le fer de lance l'un
des fers de lance
sur le plan territorial du tourisme
d'affaires c'est pour ça que la
manifestation qui a été organisée à
l'initiative de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est absolument
importante parce qu'elle permet encore
une fois de venir en soutien des
professionnels du tourisme sur ce
segment extrêmement concurrentiel comme
l'a rappelé françois navarro à l'instant
qui est celui de l'événementiel
l'organisation de salons et de congrès
et donc par rapport à cette activité-là
saint quentin en yvelines parce qu'il ya
à proximité avec sa clé parce qu'on a
tout un tissu économique absolument
majeur est parce qu on a aussi un
calendrier qui va s'y prêter avec par
exemple la ryder cup et d'autres
manifestations culturelles sportives qui
vont aussi draîné du tourisme d'affaires
et bien pour toutes ces raisons là c'est
un pôle d'excellence en matière de
tourisme d'affaires
et c'est pour ça que la région ile de
france souhaite accompagner une
cinquantaire divine dans une très bonne
articulation pour que ça puisse être
l'une des locomotives en matière de
tourisme d'affaires et dynamisme et une
arnaque question justement sur les
perspectives et ce qu'il va y avoir de
nouvelles infrastructures en ile de
france sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour encore plus d
nous dynamise et justement ce tourisme
d'affaires alors la perspective sur
l'île de france au global il ya deux
événements qui sont essentiels c'est le
13 septembre l'annnonce de paris en tout
cas comme ville hôte des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 et
saclay qui retenu comme candidature de
la france pour l'expo de 2025 et on sait
que l'expo universelle à une occasion
encore plus touristique que les jeux
olympiques puisqu'elle du retrait de six
mois et donc c'est l'ensemble du
territoire francilien et autour de
saclay qui en bénéficiera merci
messieurs en tout cas pour ces
éclairages sur ce secteur du tourisme
d'affaires
merci alors françois navarro évoqué il
ya quelques instants l'attribution des
jo 2000 24 à paris il en est justement
question dans le reste de l'actualité
économique
mais nous irons aussi à rambouillet où
s'est ouvert une nouvelle enseigne
culturelle
l'actualité économique résumé en une
minute trente c'est maintenant c'est
désormais officiel paris accueillera les
jeux olympiques en 2024
une bonne nouvelle pour la capitale
française mais aussi pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
puisque quatre sites accueilleront des
épreuves le golf national
le vélodrome lille de loisirs et la
colline d'elancourt
s'il est encore trop tôt pour chiffrer
les retombées économiques il est certain
que les jets auront un impact positif
sur le tourisme dans notre territoire
le 13 septembre dernier l'ancienne
culture a ouvert son 76e magasins en
france à rambouillet dans les yvelines
près de 1500 mètres carrés sont dédiés à
la lecture à la musique mon corps aux
loisirs créatifs une nouvelle offre
culturelle qui permet également de
booster l'économie locale
on semble sur une base de 20,6 à six
employés dont une vingtaine qui ont été
embauchés du bassin de rambouillet
c'est-à-dire sondés rambolitains ou bien
habite juste à côté de rambouillet est
bonne nous escomptons embauche encore
quelques personnes
les mois qui viennent pour la fin
d'année ou bien si notre activité adeler
sort nous espérons augmenter nos
effectifs
enfin voici une appli qui va
certainement faire faire des économies à
de nombreuses yvelinois et par la même
occasion faire fonctionner l'économie
locale enzo désormais disponible dans
notre département permet de trouver un
dépanneur 7 jours sur 7 pas de mauvaise
surprise car vous savez à l'avance
combien vous allez payer et les
dépanneurs sont tous des professionnels
de confiance comme le précise
l'application disponible sur l'appstore
et google plaît cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin mais avant voyons
ensemble les rendez vous économiques qui
vous attendent
vendredi 22 septembre la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines organise une matinée consacrée
à la reprise d'entreprise
au programme marché de la reprise étapes
de la démarche mais aussi des échanges
c'est à versailles
l'entrée est gratuite et puis si vous
avez un projet de d'entreprise et que
vous voulez déterminé bien ces
conditions de viabilité
le ski cube organise mardi 26 septembre
un atelier intitulé étude de marché la
réaliser soi même c'est de 9 heures à 11
heures la participation est gratuite
mais l'inscription est obligatoire
voilà c'est la fin de ce premier numéro
de la saison merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve mardi 3 octobre pour un
nouveau 7 8 et co consacrée notamment
aux entreprises de notre territoire qui
exportent en europe
à très bientôt
[Musique]